[Music] what is going on there citizens of
the reject Nation we're going to watch two
episodes of echo but maybe this is just in one
video I don't know what are you guys thinking
about the show so far Coy let's start with
you uh really enjoying it surprised at the
tone really impressed at the darkness that's
what oh that's efficient John I'm ready to
love the rest of this oh shills all righty guys
well I'm ready to get into it leave a like on
this video that'd be very much appreciated
also subscribe cck the notification we get
notifi on our reaction for the next episode
of EO is up also thank you to pre set down
these highlights full length through watch
where you s with your own copy of EO that
is available for our super sexual rejects
over at our patreon page whether joh I cover
several things exclusively with highlights
and watch alongs included let's get into
[Music] it I like to fish May oh cool wonder if
they're all going to open in the past who says
it's the past yes the distant future future
Earth has been returned to its natural order
it's pass it's can't confirm oh this is an
IMAX aspect change tell by the aspect ratio
nice damn damn they threw down lenses
that was beautiful wow cool damn it's
like ancient lacrosse he caught
the golden [Applause] snitch JK
Rowling culturally appropriated chak
talk culture she would never do such
[Music] a uhoh get off the pot man oh
the ultimate player enters the Frank
that's really cool how they built these
sets great trapezius definition
this guy's his whole own
team you up [__] that's
that's spit was come at me
bro team red or team blue blue always red versus
blue I really like that the dude is
just sitting waiting for like they need
me oh the stakes it's the name of
one of Jake Sully's kids except it's
spelled differently sports for banishment it's
hardcore oh [Music]
damn it dude is a beast got
money riding on [Applause]
you damn blue team's really catching up since that
one guy came Christ Tom Brady over here doing the
work I love that there's letting this play out as
its own story get in there yeah there you go oh up
final point something like this is actually really
difficult to choreograph I can't even imagine
especially all this crowd work you got to do with
everyone yeah and all the dodging and jumping and
Diving for a sport none of us know like it's
impressive storytelling without the Sport
rules
do
Dodge okay so it seems like there's some
type of like omnipresent tethered Through
Time memory thing happening here a tempor she
connected to her connected to her Bloodlines
memories oh my God dude's eyes about to pop out
of his head credits o opening scene done well
this is like the True Detective
opening well I know HBO presents
Echo I noticed Vincent denafo was not
one of the main credited ah they don't
want people to know it's him trying to keep it a
surprise there he is but he's
right here yeah who's that
guy H the visual echo on the title
nice flash of lightning oh flash of the fire
alarm good old
biscuits damn it's smart instead of a
doorbell never
it's not made to be Offroad not
good so demanding he just brought you all that
stuff no thanks for the Pop-Tarts different
poptarts it is yes many moon come CH hey
this depicts the animals talking to the
wind symbolizing the harmony with Mother Earth
sure it does he's bullshitting it's amazing by
the damn theam theam by the damn took me a while
to get that oh it's great they're subconsciously
drawn to by the damn thing but the aesthetic of
our Cita is a little more south Westy do you have
any of those Navajo Rugs oh boy sure anthropology
they have how all the ethnically ambiguous you
could shots fired drive over to uh anthropology
and get your Navajo rug but that's all stuff from
Mad report if you buy Mador Scully I show you're
getting authentic handmade art from Humble Native
American arti go away we'll take it ah good do
you have any of those um bolo ties bolo ties
does a chicken have lips you don't have to make
Caucasian people look stupid in order to elevate
your what are they I don't know I'm just focused
on came out what is that oh it's all this you get
your income tax check back or what I don't know
why you got to be all somehow I just helped you
with that sale with the N hos you know I got
better care in that piece of [__] whoa whoa
Marvel Spotlight slow down swear light no no I
need way smaller how about that wow I need teeny
tiny like like a little hummingbird's tongue
he's going to be like George Lopez and Blue
Beetle he's going to be like Tech genius John you
sound so racist right now he's clearly Mexican Yi
for all your hard work extra busy with Maya back
in town and oh I was so excited when I took Chris
to the rink yesterday just like casual D how does
he know well Maya is being like don't tell people
I'm here but I'm going to show up to roller
skating rinks I'm walk around outside in broad
daylight uhoh what a surprise somebody's grandbaby
having a birthday bash I don't know about we need
to talk yeah some stuff you should have told me
she really does have an intimidating presence
God there's going to be a cool action scene
that happens here all on skates M's back she
came by to see you not likely the guy from
reservation dogs told me about it what you
after you don't want to know oh this like Voyer
shot right here I'm wondering if it's a k k Loki
holding the story and it's my understanding that
she's just passing through town and nothing more
just if you can encourage her to stick to
her plan pass through town without causing
any trouble and get the hell out of Dodge it is
a very interesting street level world they're ex
deciding to explore here in okah this culture
this does not feel like a Disney Plus show at
all like the leap between well when I heard
street level I thought oh New York City but
then to have it focused not in a skate rink
instead of it just being like Maya's people
are good people you could feel like the
tension dir that goes on around this town
yeah oh you going to hold up that
train we're going
splunking she's jumping on a train I just
want a whole compilation and documentary
about the people who just make these
random uis for like apps and shows
yeah buddy let's go let's go cool
woo Mission Impossible dead echoing I mean
the visuals are great I do feel like she is
surrounded by a lot more interesting characters
than herself though right right now yeah everyone
else is just big and charismatic and she's so
nuanced and subtle I want to know more about her
do speed woo cool like transition
they always do that great subtle
pushing follow your heartbeat damn how is
her heart so steady at A Moment Like This
training me she is badass [Music]
though oh lighting's [Applause]
rad
nice the
Stars interesting
cut come on hereditary this dude that
is a lot of grip strength great treads
on those shoes too you think she has the
six-pack definitely definely strong core
red light the mark of any cool new Ora show
yes someone's developing photos in this train
car camera like a hummingbird's
tongue it's like
startech a weird shot
yeah God damn it damn it Pok me after the call
right now I'm in the middle of a mission sry
guy of the chair I like that he's got it like
handsfree cuz he's such a safe guy he's not
hold again sometimes he's impressionable in
the right direction I really appreciate it
oh what do you think of that toxic waste fat
maybe the stuff that made Daredevil or the
team Ninja Turtles the same ooze oh that pink
slime they make McNuggets out of more likely
that all my band stolen gear come on
oh that's why they off-roading I didn't
put that together somehow like a fool hold on you
idiot come on Maya whoa she's going in
damn got a fully stocked utility belt we
don't know what she's trying to retrieve
right now right not to my knowledge this
just Fisk supplies it's a Priceless piece
of art the rabbit in the snow oh yeah oh
oh no no no no it's met metal but still
that hurt has an experience thank God she
doesn't have a right yeah I mean that was
still crunchy better than the alternative
In This Moment oh mystical Powers let's go see
what [Music] happens unlock the spirit of your
ancestors do some magic [__] to this train the
strength
oo oh cool not bad so that's kind of like what
we were talking about with Kori like it it's
a moment of like Discovery and like I don't know
I've already felt more like her being disoriented
by the powers than just having them that's
fair yeah it's true oh oh jeez Terminator leg
yeah come on where is she you're doing great
biscuits biscuits biscuits out here with no
training o damn this like a video game
Mission oh Jesus Christ way over there get over
there bud you got one job to do feel like that'd
be burning her [Music] hand oh goody why
do these action sceds always lead into a
tunnel this is crazy this is
[Music] [Laughter] crazy yeah
make sure you clarify that wo boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy not bad not bad she's been watching
Fast and Furious [Music] good job biscuits
you really brought the gravy today
you almost died we almost almost
died like corre
communication that was really funny I took
it back steal anything she plant something
yeah she need know what was in there we have no
idea what she's doing I love her little Smiles
of relief the train made it to New York City
yeah it must be some Fisk products going to be
unable yeah that guy track suit mafia
hey just came in top stop Good Times
cat yo I'm pack this unload these
drum heads D9 X dis Disney's X-Men
97 District 9 on Twitter oh oh yeah she did
PL something not message I'm
coming for you like an epoxy
bomb o Dam they they really blow a place up
every phone in the house I am very
curious to see what the marriage
between the fantasy mystical side
and the street level side will feel
like well it's starting to accelerate right
like that soon is the first time we've seen
her actualize it it's building to it yeah when
didd you get the call just before I called you
15 minutes ago man this guy's going to be a bad
guy yeah he moves like a fighter too much heard
from the other stops transfers up and down
that whole line everyone did them exactly
as usual d x was no different so what are you
saying that's the one that blew we had nothing
to do with this we keep our heads down and our
mouths shut any crap rolls downhill it won't land
on you it'll land on me and I brought plenty of
bags shouldn't he have texted that in sign link
which little hand signal emojis don't get it
guys she's officially back in town yeah
really oh uh upgrade look at all the bows I
really uh miss you around here 20 years way
too long I go um get things yeah Chop
Chop if uh somebody comes in just uh
holler oh fun it's like a comic book
panel yeah leg upgrade sure
oh yeah he's got to do some
modifications they're Armory
melted a job well done sir that in the back holy
[__] it's made of vibranium
yeah the real one take uh time
for me to to build that's temporary
don't you run off with it that's a
spare that's the woman from the vision maybe she
doesn't really understand her Heritage that's a
Chata aafa so speak can to learn together o
oh yeah when they emerged turned into human
beings your uh grandmother oh would Trace Your
Roots back to uh Chata aapa oh that's cool so
it's that direct line ancestors would watch out
for uh family in times of need it's interesting
too that they gave this rendering an
actual fertility esque physique it's
like a detail I never would have expected
your grandmother knows all that you U ask
her yeah I didn't ask to hear your life story
and by extension my life and our people's
life story enough of my own upbringing
uhoh new car chola whis get borrowed
man yes speak of the
[Music]
devil I don't think she saw you man I think
you're good that was amazing oh I just admire
it you know have a good one one that shot was
perfect I showed up for Kingpin and Maya but
it's these supporting characters who I think
are really elevated the show to another level
man it's been like 18 hours pok's going to kill
me I love you man he really messed up Biscuit's
here again um pretty new PlayStation and I'm
not trying to brag or nothing but you know I
I wouldn't be doing this if I didn't need the
money to figure my grandma's truck it's now at
a low low price of 100 bucks damn dude I'll buy
it meetting Bonnie everyone's from reservation
dogs what happened to the truck I was driving
in back roads and I might have been a little
distracted are you okay and what what was the
trouble no trouble at all I'm okay Billy Jack's
okay Maya's okay but the truck it's oh no oh
dude man what Maya is here she's in Maha did
I say Maya I said jumbalaya I'm losing you please
uh call the chip life you want buy play thank you
biscuits where is she over and out biscuits don't
you dare do this to me a I really feel like the
community and the people everyone has distinct
personalities and they feel real they feel alive
yeah like they're off doing stuff right now and
I believe that in the show which I don't often
[Laughter] filled with
protein I think she
has that's a fair point already doing
business there though and she knows
itch introduce a little [Music]
chaos ooh I like her color
scheme his name is
awesome just low see even though they're at odds I
feel like this could be one of the potential times
where like a guy you don't want to be a villain
maybe falls into that side of things but you but
maybe he's got like some kind of point that they
could articulate in a sophisticated way yeah cuz
her indifference to everyone that she actually
does love is going to be like I see an opportunity
in a character like that in a lot of these
characters that so many of these shows present
and squander and I hope they nail here because
they could because she obviously needs to figure
out how much she cares about these people and he
might be the one to be right while she's wrong and
right
Bonnie oh no girls are always fighting women am I
ouchie
shoot your way to the
Past damn thank you Georgia all right all
right beautiful that was truly like a a a
under there wasn't a lot of action it but it
all the dialogue was so action-packed like
the end was the only time like obviously
the train scene but they really let that
be subdued I was afraid this episode would end
with like a third Act cof yeah that was really
cool he was in the trade is that not the name
of the show there actually is a new comic called
darev EO it's pretty Dar devil echo or is he
why isn't he in Oklahoma if you went all the
way to She-Hulk land why didn't you come all
the way to echoland why isn't he helping out
the reservation land just everywhere man he
could be everywhere that's why there so many
opening credits why wasn't he there should be
white saving going on why isn't Charlie Cox's
top billing why isn't he the original chak
yeah I think it's really good there is this
part in my mind is the problem with social
media rhetoric that can often circulate and
just the Optics around Disney deciding to because
they've been toying with their release strategy I
actually really like what they did with what if
surprisingly that one a day that sounded like
a terrible idea first just for our end and then
then ended up panning out really well just like
how it paded out really well for everyone who
bought a shirt at reject Nation shop.com they
really where you can I love I always love John's
like transition whenever whenever I'm the shirt
he does the first the hair and then look at my
shirt I got to get the hair out of the way see
Shir hair love I love your designs so much and I
just want to accentuate them anyway thank you all
who been buying teas and uh you look good while
doing it too and I mean come on look at buff
comfortable oh my God that's what I like to see
that's what I like to see I thought that this was
a really solid episode and I like everything that
it's building to my favorite part about the show
thus far and we're going to watch a third episode
just a little bit so I I'd really prefer if we
just kept this really short I mean it gents is The
Supporting Cast I think The Supporting Cast has
really been a Saving Grace to it because well I
think everything's shot really well I'm intrigued
by the chalk talk culture uh I I am a little bit
like semi nervous about what what's It ultimately
going to meld into once we go full uh chock toop
mysticism because it's the street level stuff that
I find the most intriguing at this moment in time
that but I'm completely open-minded is seeing what
they ultimately integrate I think my one concern
is pretty apparent if you like actually watch
the reaction is that uh yeah I'm just not super
emotionally invested in Maya right now and I I
have no qualms or apprehensions there was nothing
about me that was the least bit concerned about
someone who is uh deaf and that can keep I feel
like some people well is because she can't talk
that it could be a limitation I'm like no some
of my favorite performances ever are usually just
quiet body language performances with minimal
dialogue so I didn't think there would be some
type of barrier there uh right now I can't quite
put my finger on it granted it's just the second
episode but we did spend a decent amount of time
with her in Hawkeye while I like her here more and
while I like what she serves as a plot narrative
device going forward it is everything everyone and
everything else surrounding her I'm talking like
in terms of technicality of film making uh cast
everything around her I find way more interesting
than just her right now and that's my main is
concern with the journey moving forward that could
all that's all subject to change in like literally
one episode I'm not even quite sure what it is
that they need to do because I felt like last
episode they bombarded us with a cacophony of
information about her and the and the journey
uh but there there is something that is keeping
me at a distance and I'm not quite sure what it
is just yet maybe I'll be able to articulate it
later on uh but it's not at all detering me from
enjoying uh the show or right I think it's like
a cool criminal under I think it's a Cool Crime
world I like how it develops into the MCU I think
it's cool that we're getting this Fisk expansion
um the the Shadow the pull that he casts over
everything is really neat so I really I really
am liking it uh but that that is the one thing
I guess not so much a criticism but something
I'm craving right now craving the hunting for
it COI I personally care more about Ekko here
than I did in Hawkeye as well but it's starting to
get I I I see what you're saying uh by the end of
this episode I was starting to feel like I wasn't
thinking about that as much because that that had
affected me the first episode and like half of
this one but with the Bonnie stuff and with the
character starting to come into her like I feel
like you know she's not in town now that she's in
town I'm like okay we're all starting to bring
these disperate story lines to me caring about
Eko CU it's her relationship that's starting to
be more apparent and feel so I think it's going
to be for Me Maybe for you as well kind of like
lowkey season 2 where we were both worried that
he was just like I'm an agent of the TVA and
then by episode five we were like oh I I see
why they had to build all that to him so I think
as long as that turn happens I'll be okay but I
definitely understand where you're coming from
now I hope that happens uh I really like that
this show and I I think I Now understand why
they did this all as one binge I think it's
because the audience they're appealing to isn't
used to slow content uh I think that you have a
show that is going to have a lot more dialogue
than action and I think that people are probably
waiting for third act fight scenes or for big bads
and I think when you've got a 5H hour delivery of
something the things on social media are going
to be like deevil Fight King Pin fight good and
then they won't have to worry about people not
talking about like the dialogue scenes that would
inevitably not be part of social conversation
so I think the release model is now starting to
make more sense to me with this particular show
because this episode I really enjoyed but I'm
not necessarily the target demo anymore uh I like
slowburn True Detectives shows I like more drama
and so I think my my attention span after growing
up with VHS is aware that this exists and not all
of their demo is so I think releasing these day
and date might actually work out for their favor
because social media reactions will be about
other things yeah so I'm enjoying especially
get your Netflix characters over here with a
model that resembles something more of Netflix
this definitely feels more HBO Netflix and I think
that'll be the conversation yeah yeah yeah I no
I think it's a lot of Pros I think there's like
like it's primarily a a Pros experience this is
in my upper half of of Disney Plus show so far
yeah I like her more than iron fist I like I
like the character of Eko more than iron fist but
but at least he was like enjoyably bad yes that's
true and Defenders we could all be like why are
they going to him so much we got get these guys
over here my favorite part about him but yeah I
I'm enjoying this more than I expected um and I
think that it feels a lot more like uh David Mack
art than I expected it's got a really wonderful
pacing and and it feels like the opening the
opening credits if I'd seen separately I'd be
like they're really trying to be True Detective
but the show actually feels like that kind of
grit yeah yeah I'm not saying it's his darkest
D detective I'm saying so far it's earned its
opening credits yeah yeah yeah I'm curi I I I
agree with pretty much everything that you guys
have expressed I liked all the things that
you guys like John Wiz he agrees everything
I I think I have uh a a guess as to what might
not fully be clicking together here because uh I
was kind of noticing it during the episode and
I do think it's interesting that they have so
many people cast from reservation dogs because
what I love the most so far about this is the
times when it's reminding me of that show because
that show has a very unique strange but also very
intimate kind of tone where you feel like you're
just absorbing the vibe of the both indigenous
culture and this a town kind of like this and
so I feel like it's neat that they pulled these
actors together and when you're focusing on that
stuff it's when it feels the most organic and like
a real story and that stuff kind of helps Maya's
character because everyone's like is she back what
do we do about it like everyone's so kind of up
in arms about her but I feel like when you go to
Maya she's kind of just in this Lone Wolf action
badass story and like all the interesting nuanced
character beats are mostly through other people
and this episode introduces the idea of like
okay she's going to have some you know magical
link to the the first Chaka and the power that
lies within and that in the moment I was like oh
this feels like Miss Marvel like this this feels
kind of something directly pulled from Playbook
it doesn't feel quite as fleshed as when you're
just with the towns folk in they're dealing with
you know like what were you doing out with the car
this train hey what do you know about this and
everyone's kind of like shuffling truths around
that stuff feels nuanced and then you also have
the third show which is you know Daredevil and
Kingpin and [__] like that and I like that we
don't have to be always doing that I like that
that can have distance but still affect where we
are here but I do feel like there are three shows
happening one of them is a very pleasant surprise
that you're like man if they could sustain this
and and yeah merge all of these this could be
something really really special and uh I I can
still see the potential for that but it was during
the train sequence where I was torn because I was
like this is cool I like a low light kind of set
piece like this but I also was finding myself like
not checked out but just like kind of at a plateau
of of thrill in that moment uh and I'm like if I
if we had maybe a couple more intimate moments
with Maya or times to see her soften or deal
with the struggles that she's not maybe going
to show to everybody else because she's got to
maintain that tough face that that demeanor you
know I feel like if we could get some moments to
peer into her with a Nuance versus the requisite
stuff that we a know about her and B often feeds
the backstory of a character like this I feel
like that would pull it all together but uh as
it stands right now I like all the elements that
they have and I believe that they can accentuate
them all to the utmost but yeah it's like there
are three things I like Happening Here one of
them I think is pretty pretty great one of them's
pretty good and the other one I'm like yeah this
is the meat and potatoes that you need to do a
badass you know again Lone Wolf taking it to the
Man kind of story but uh that's the piece I'm
waiting for the the most like reason to connect
to beyond all the requisit stuff because of what
kind of show you're watching yeah um I feel like
there's more to definitely say uh in terms of what
may be working or way not be working however this
is designed to be a binge experience so I'm going
to reserve I'm going to intentionally hold back
intentionally hold back some stuff so that way I'm
just not like next episode like never mind it'll
be easier just to kind of give a full encapsulated
review uh once we're done with the fifth episode
so Al righty guys uh what do you what do you what
do you think about Maya huh yeah there you go
that's a question want to name my band plateau
of thrill I don't know what to say we play Red
deaded to put it down would you rob a train leave
it in the comments the best vehicle to Rob uh
subscribe leave a like thank you to everyone
who about see us for the next episode cheers
peeps Lex it is time for your patron of the day
shout out your first one for 2024 and I got to
Fathom what your New Year's resolution is and
that is to buy more batteries I can understand
that running out of batteries it's a pain in
the ass sometimes you're like trying to turn
on the TV you look forever for that remote and
then you're like okay here it is time to turn
on the television and then bam you can't turn it
on because there's no batteries in there it is
a very frustrating process once in a while you
want to take out one of your toys you know to
pleasure yourself but then bam batteries don't
work so you call up your mom you're like Mom
I need batteries for my action figure like what
action figure you still play with action figures
Lex I never knew you play with action figures
I just need batteries mom can you please drop
off some batteries and then she's like well send
me a photo then you send her a photo of it that
leads to an awkward conversation and then you
go damn I should have followed through my New
Year's resolution a year supply of batteries
yeah doublea's aaa's D's Vol now you got to
have an awkward ass conversation with your mom
cuz you were irresponsible you didn't stick to
your goals yeah list next time L for list Lex you
get a pretty good deal on Amazon always double a
AAA MCO they'll drive a drone to your house
I don't know why you didn't do it Lex not my
family problem now yeah it's okay anyway good luck
with 2024 dealing with this trauma again [Music]